welcome back now myla for
education
uh also we have some yeah
also have some subs today sitting in for
uh moffat as alan bernstein
for nelson
you're not here
aidan ankenberg
uh connie lane for
representative porter brian sullivan for
representative mullen
and mary beth walls for
and she's not here yet
anyway okay
so we're going to start here on
executive session
public hearing i'm sorry i'm ahead of
myself public hearing a non-german
amendment
0.20220734h
to senate bill
36.
and i recognize glenn cordelli for a
testament
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you
colleagues
for the record glenn cordelli
representing tuftonboro moultonborough
in sandwich in the beautiful lakes
region
this is a non-german amendment to senate
bill 236
the
purpose
for this amendment
relates to
confusion basically over the term
secondary school
there has
developed
a situation
in at least one middle school
in which
teachers
are teaching
same grade
pre-algebra and algebra classes that are
taught in the high school
they both have
student loans and under the student loan
forgiveness program
one teacher is receiving uh their full
17 000
in forgiveness but the other teacher
is not
because they are teaching
the
eighth grade
algebra classes
so as you'll see in the letter i think
that it should have made its way around
from
a division chief at the u.s department
of education
it explains
the situation and the confusion over
what is a secondary school
in several places as pointed out in
there
secondary school
is defined
as
uh a junior high school program
uh in several places it is defined um as
anything above elementary school and
actually in rules um
uh
they are two different categories
there's elementary and then secondary
and that's all that is covered um in
rules so
uh secondary is clearly not elementary
so would be
junior high school
as well as high school level
so in the non-german
amendment
as you can see in lines
through 20
it defines
teachers in grades 7 through 12
to be considered secondary school
teachers
which will satisfy
the
student loan
office and allow
both
teachers teaching the same course
to receive their full loan forgiveness
rather than just uh the half as is uh
currently uh been decided um by the uh
loan office
so uh that's the basis of the um
uh the amendment um representative hill
who has brought this um
forward um
uh will be here to testify he's
in another committee at the moment
as is representative hopson who is the
prime sponsor so i'm uh about fifth down
in the line uh in relation to this
amendment but uh it's my pleasure to
present it to you
anybody have any questions
woodcock
thank you chairman good morning glenn
good morning as we go as regards the uh
license on a licensure or certification
um by the state for for faculty and
those grade levels um
below the the typical high school level
below the nine or 12
uh those in the middle school does that
is that going to have a repercussion or
a domino effect on licensure
certification the requirements being
different for those two grade levels
i i don't believe so
because as specified in lines 18 19 it's
for the purposes of this program that
it's uh defining the grade 7
through 12 teacher as secondary
and
in
rules now
it's basically just elementary or
secondary education
so there won't be any certification
changes on the state level right okay
correct thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you
representative
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i actually have uh two
questions one is i noticed in this in
the
current law
in different places it call it
references a separate organization
consisting of grades seven through nine
or a separate organization four through
eight
um by calling it a separate organization
does that mean that it's not a school
district
or
is it can it be tuition schools
um
is there a particular statute you're
referring to that where that is
distinction is made
in your amendment 189. okay i'm sorry on
line 13
and then it's repeated again on line 15.
right that's that's in current statute
now
um it's existing right yes it's existing
language but i'm wondering if
that
that means that um
that covers uh tuition schools for
tuition purposes and um
you know uh prenda and those kinds of i
believe this is talking about public
schools um
in this uh section of law
okay and my second question is
how can we um
at the state level influence uh
federal teacher loan forgiveness
programs
um
i think as indicated in the
accompanying
letter
i think that if we clarify
that uh as we did in lines 18 to 20
that those grades are
uh considered secondary for the purposes
of this program i think that that
from everything i've been told uh should
satisfy it so that the teacher can get
their full
loan forgiveness payment
any other questions yes
sure thank you very much mr chair um is
there going to be any um
um
retroactive uh
um uh i guess loan forgiveness for maybe
a teacher who
who taught in seventh or eighth grade
prior to the
establishment of this policy
um
i i don't believe so but uh i'm not in
the loan forgiveness
business but i
uh i would not expect so but
so thank you very much thanks for taking
my question do you think then it's um
it's fair to uh to move forward with
this while other teachers may have been
excluded from from loan forgiveness
yes
thank you i get
one point remember some years ago on the
committee would pass the bill allowing
students to take
courses and then they'd get credit for
those courses in high school if they
were taking a lower grade i remember in
our high school
algebra for example in the eighth grade
and spanish
and taken in the eighth grade was the
same course as taking in the ninth grade
the same books and everything and so i
remember when i was on the school board
because it was law we passed it so that
those students can get the credit for
what they took in the eighth grade and i
know londonderry even starts soon in the
seventh grade they can take algebra in
the eighth grade they can take geometry
so i mean depending on the student they
have to meet the qualification so yeah i
think this is
probably a good bill and probably being
done already so but for the loan
forgiveness yeah i think it's fair just
my comment
and uh
oh
represent milo uh thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
it's it's more of a statement i think
than a question
and it's a follow-up to uh
representative luna's statement
i think the loan forgiveness is a good
program
the dilemma is is that you've got other
teachers
that are also teaching kids
and you've got elementary teachers who
for example
are providing a
a baseline for learning math for example
and yet they get no credit for that
so this is not a criticism
of the amendment here
but it's a criticism of the policy
that you take a section of teachers
and you say okay
you can have a special deal here but the
others can't
and i think i object to the theory
that you
take a particular group of teachers and
provide them with preferential treatment
rather than dealing with teachers in
general that provide the foundation
for math etc so that's that's really
more of a criticism
for the concept of
segmenting out certain people to get
certain things and not recognizing the
value of others by giving them the same
benefit so it's just a statement thank
you thank you
um uh and i expect um uh if
representative hill makes it here he's
been uh very involved in in this issue
um he uh i'm sure would be uh glad to
um explore further your your comment
what's up thank you i don't know if
that's for you for you is the chair or
representative cordelia can you explain
to me
what n h h e a f the supplemental piece
what that organization is supplemental
piece that came with the amendment
um i i am not sure what the acronym
stands for uh perhaps uh representative
hill is aware of that um i was trying to
figure that out myself but uh uh
yeah
i'm not sure okay
representative do you have the answer
so thank you very much mr chair i
believe it stands for new hampshire
higher education assistance foundation
and it
i think traditionally
involves itself in
in fafsa completion student fafsa
completion for
sophomores and juniors in in high school
and it also advises students and
families on their uh their ability to um
to obtain um uh uh loans and and
scholarships for higher education great
thank you so much for your clarification
thank you mr chair
the senator paul
i mean representative that's okay
thank you mr
and thank you for taking my question i'm
just wondering about certification
versus what you teach
so if you were an eighth grade algebra
teacher and you were certified in
elementary ed
but you're teaching you've you've been
hired to teach the algebra class are you
still qualified or not is it it looks
like it's not based on certification but
rather
if you have a bachelor's degree
and you are teaching the science is that
right or
do we know that uh
i'm
not sure of that but um
uh
you know it it seems that um there are
subjects that are um
offered um both in high school and in
the upper
middle school if you will or
in within any secondary that basically
are similar similar programs
so if i'm not certified in mathematics
but i am a certified teacher i have
a bachelor's degree in elementary ed
and i've been hired to teach that i
would get the long forgiveness do you
think
uh i am not that familiar with the
provisions of the loan forgiveness
program okay thank you
any more questions
okay thank you and i guess we'll recess
for a few minutes and see if we can find
greg hill
i know senator kahn is in
the education committee downstairs in
the senate i was just there
so
well representative hill to speak on
232.
thank you mr chairman
thank you i hope i didn't hold anyone up
you did but
well i apologize
to everyone
um
i'm here on to speak on a uh an
amendment to 236
mostly to explain the situation that
happened in my school district
as most of us
are aware
often times when you hear a story from a
constituent that just sounds so crazy
it you find out
generally it is crazy and there's a
important piece missing
in this case it wasn't um it is crazy as
far as i can see
the situation was
in winter swamp school district
we had three math teachers
in grade eight
they applied for
loans for
education continuing education
two of them applied with one lender
one of them applied with a different
lender
when it came to the teacher forgiveness
program
the two that applied with one lender
that lender looked at our statutes
and
deemed
the reimbursement to be
based on a
high school level
or
secondary level
they paid or reimbursed seventeen
thousand five hundred
the one teacher that chose a different
carrier
their
legal team looked at our statutes
and had an opposite view and said that
they were
a primary or
elementary school
teacher
and they will reimburse five thousand
dollars
so
all this amendment does
is say for purposes of the teacher loan
forgiveness program
k through 6
will be considered elementary school
7 through 12 will be considered
a secondary school
and that's all it does
it allows
you know we have letter upon letter here
from the superintendent who's saying it
really doesn't matter they're all
teaching in 8th grade
this high school
level math so they should be here they
went as far as
to the u.s department of education and
because our statutes in different areas
refer to
those grades
in an ambiguous way or in different
sections one way or another rather than
try to change those different sections
it just made sense for them to have
something to point to as c for purposes
of this this is the legislative intent
so with that i'll be happy to answer any
questions
but i hope you consider any questions
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much representative hill for taking
my question you mentioned that the
particular teachers in question were
teaching high school level math in
eighth grade
in that school are you aware of any
eighth grade math teachers who are not
teaching high school level math and
would would otherwise
maybe
not feel that they were entitled to the
seventeen thousand five hundred dollars
in federal loan forgiveness
uh thank you for your question
representative i i am not aware
um two things i'm not aware that they
were exclusively teaching
what we would call high school math
i'm only going by
the description that was sent to the
department of education
and from the testimony that i've given
you from
the teacher herself
i'm not sure it was exclusively
one way or the other i think they do
incorporate
i think they say here pre-algebra as
well as algebra 1 classes so
for me i consider algebra 1
high school and pre-algebra i consider
8th grade but i may be wrong
yes thank you very much um and and as a
as a as a follow-up then uh is there a
distinction to be made among
let's say seventh and eighth grade
teachers
who
may not be teaching
high school level math courses or
science courses and i'm not i'm not
trying to talk about exclusively
teaching
high school math and science but ones
who don't teach any high school level
math and science like for instance
some schools might have a class called
seventh grade math
and um and maybe i'm a math teacher at
one of those schools and i teach
seventh grade math i teach um um
um
let me just say three you know three
blocks of seventh grade math uh every
day
um
uh and i don't teach anything else uh
would would would that teacher feel that
that they met the
requirements of this section or the
section is amended for um uh to be
considered to be a high school teacher
i'm just trying to figure out what what
motivated these teachers
to um
to to want to make this distinction and
whether or not it's being being applied
and and i guess how it's being applied
in this thank you for your question um
if i understand it correctly
i want to make sure that that the
committee is aware this is not just
dealing with
um science and math
teachers um this is
the amendment speaks only to
7th through 12th being considered
secondary
regardless of the subject matter that
you're teaching 7th through 12th
and
k through
6 being considered
um elementary that's all it does and
that
and the reason i think it's simpler to
do it that way
is because that's what this program that
that reimburses
deals with it doesn't deal with
the subject matter in any way shape or
form
so it doesn't there's no distinction
that i've seen in any of these teacher
forgiveness programs that we have here
from any of the
lending institutions
they're not they're not talking about
what's what's taught or
what percentage or by whom
is that
that's how i understand your question
thank you
any other questions represent tana
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question so there's no um
so this is basically a federal program
that we don't have at the state level
but we have state
financial institutions that deal with
student loans
who are making different decisions and
we're trying to make it equal is that
would that be a good summary of what
i think you should have been the one
testifying representative thank you very
much
that says it perfectly
okay any other questions seeing none on
the close the hearing on
sb 236. thank you and we're going to
open the hearing on
the don jermaine amendment 2022-14318
to senate bill 352 and i recognize
representative glenn cordelli
thank you mr chairman
thank you
again colleagues uh glenn cordelli
representing tuftonboro molten varane
sandwich in the beautiful lakes region
and
i am introducing a non-germain amendment
to senate bill 352.
um
this uh amendment um has come about
based on a contact i had with a
counselor a couple of months ago
and it relates to a
federal
grant program
that
is being piloted in a number of
districts in new hampshire
and this
this
program
relates to
student behavioral and and wellness
issues and
as part of the
requirements of the program
counselors are required to enter into a
third-party database
um
personally identifiable information
about students
including
a name address sacid
and other behavioral issues i believe
if a counselor sees a student more than
once they are supposed to enter
information into this database
for tracking of
possible behavioral issues
the counselor
feels that uh this is in violation of um
her ethical standards
as a member of the counselor profession
and um
as
pointed out in the
american school counselors association
materials
school counselors recognized primary
obligation regarding confidentiality
is to the student but balance that
obligation with an understanding of the
family and their legal and inherent
rights to be the guiding voice of their
children's lives
and there are more things in the
asca
literature about
confidentiality
this
situation
escalated
within the past month
and that the
uh teacher was
threatened with being written up for its
abortion insubordination if they did not
enter this
student
private information into the database
i reached out to the department
of education
and their legal staff looked into it
and
looked into all the uh
forms and um agreements with this third
party that the
uh this one district uh has in
particular
um and uh
uh found it to be in line with federal
law
and that law is ferpa
the
family educational rights and privacy
act
in 2008
ferpa was expanded
to allow
districts
to share personally identifiable
information from student records without
parental notice or consent with any
third party designated as a school
official
including contractors consultant
volunteers
and other parties to whom the
educational agency
has outsourced institutional services or
functions
it was again expanded in 2011
to allow to again disclosure without
parental notification or constant con
consent
with organizations for the purpose of
conducting
studies
um
so i i think probably um
i i won't go against the
department of education lawyers but i
think that they're probably correct in
that it does not
violate ferpa
but the councilor still feels that it
has
it's a violation of her ethical
standards
and so she has since
recently resigned
her position in the school which
is
tears her up
because she loved her job
the department of education is working
with the third party that services
multiple districts
uh to see if they can scale back uh the
amount of uh personally identifiable
information that is being provided
to the um
to the that third party
so
not realizing that i can do much about
federal law
i've
submitted the
attached
amendment
that would at least
provide for parental notification when
student
confidential information is being
released to a third party
and
uh that
uh the department um is aware of this
and does not see any uh legal difficulty
um with this
um
in that uh the information is still
being uh provided to the third party in
line with ferpa but we're just notifying
the parents that this has occurred and i
think
you know we've talked about
parental
engagement and so forth quite often uh
this year in this committee
so i think that this is um
the least we can do in this situation
um
and uh i would uh ask for your support
for the
amendment thank you any questions
representative
thank you i i kind of feel like i'm
working behind the curtain
because i don't know
who are the third party people
and what kind of
surveys and and you know all the things
that that that this might actually
um
impede i'm wondering if the youth risk
behavioral survey for example is one of
the ones where
student information is uh given to a
third party or
you know i i would just like
more detail
uh before i make this you know decision
on this
wide-ranging bill
or amendment thank you um yeah i think
surveys are covered under a different
section of federal statute and um we're
not talking about surveys they're
actually entering this information into
a third party database
in the case of this one district it is a
uh
behavioral institute associated with
uh keene
university king college
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much representative cordelli for
taking my question would um would would
the uh
with the ferpa exceptions to um to
parental consent
uh include uh state and local
authorities within the juvenile justice
system
uh
i
i thought i
might have to look back
but there are a number of exceptions
um that i i didn't
know uh mentioned in my testimony
um
but i i have part of and this is
exciting wrong
follow-up
i can get you the ferpa no i'm i'm
actually looking at it it's a rhetorical
question okay that includes state and
local authorities within the juvenile
justice system and so my follow-up
question to that is
um uh what um um sort of implications do
you think um disclosure to um uh to a to
a parent
um uh could have
in uh in a case where uh where state and
local authorities within a juvenile
justice system are
are being involved and have you
explored exhaustively just explored
what that impact
could be
on on the families and the student and
i'd like to hear your comments on that
thank you
um
i i think that
parents have a right
to know
generally
their they're kids
so um if the school is providing uh
information on their students to a third
party um whether it's
someone in the juvenile justice system
or
elsewhere
i think parents have a right to know
we've had legislation in the past
about
law enforcement being called on students
um
and whether parents should have the
right to know that that is
going on
and i come down on the side that
parents always have the right to know
um so thank you and um and uh could you
comment a little bit on on where maybe
um abuse and neglect is involved
reported to the police are you saying or
if something like that
two authorities
two authorities correct
um
[Music]
i think that um
uh
if there is
um
let me backtrack
this is information that's being entered
into a third
party database uh nothing is being hap
happening with that uh information and
the third part by the third party
my understanding is if the third party
is presenting
information
a referral
to another agency
that parental consent
is obtained
in that case so if the third party in
this case
um is
presenting that information uh let's say
to
um a psychologist or something that the
parent would be notified
as part of this grant process
mr chair
just to be really specific on on this
this is about disclosure by the school
to a third party so it's not a third
party database
and and this is about exceptions from
the consent requirement and what i'm
hearing you suggest is that under no
circumstances should should there be any
exception whatsoever to the consent
requirement
that a student's personally identifiable
data so it's not necessarily talking
about their grades it's not necessarily
talking about
their full record but it's talking about
anything that qualifies as personally
identifiable data within a student's
record um maintained by the the lea
disclosed to a third party
pursuant to the exceptions that are that
are that are detailed under federal law
of which one of them is state and local
authorities within a juvenile justice
system
and there are others too
um that that you don't see any i
what you're saying you don't see any
situation where any exception
should be made that any parent should
receive disclosure so that such
non-consent disclosure has been made
is that your testimony
if
the school district
is
providing identifiable information
to
a juvenile
facility juvenile justice
law enforcement let's say
i think that the parents have a right to
know that
i think that uh
if
the
uh information is being disclosed um i
think
in any event the uh schools should be
talking with the parents about um what
is going on um at home um if that's
the area of your concern
but i i think that
parents need to be
is that involved
thank you mr chairman
so i've been sitting here doing a little
legal research putting on my legal hat
and it turns out that federal law
trumps state law when it comes to ferpa
that under the supremacy clause federal
law always trumps state law
having said that
most of the cases have to do with
disclosure
not with
notification like you're proposing but i
think it raises this is lawyer talk i'm
probably gonna drive you all nuts but i
think it it raises a valid question as
to whether what you're doing violates
the supremacy clause
and i think it may be putting us in a
precarious position
um if we choose to go forward with this
amendment given there's multiple state
cases that i'm finding here as i sit
here and look this up from all over the
country with over and over again state
courts and federal courts finding that
under the supremacy clause ferpa trumps
state law and all these issues
so my question is are you concerned
about that
i i believe that um
uh
that this law
the proposed amendment um deals with
just parental notification
um
it does not block the release of that
information
um under ferpa at all um
so uh
i i do not see
uh a problem
but uh but uh there again i'm not a
lawyer so in the case that
representative luna was talking about
that if you've got a case of abuse going
on say for example say you've got a
father abusing his daughter and they
want the school records from the
counselor and they're going to notify
the father of this it seems to me that
that could be a problem interfering in
the case
and certainly we've seen those kinds of
things happen all my years on child and
family law i certainly heard about those
kinds of things happening so i think one
of the perhaps unintended consequences
here may be that we're interfering with
normal
processes to protect children and i'm
wondering if
you have given that much thought and the
implications of that
in your
question
if
law enforcement was contacted i thought
i would think that law enforcement would
be doing
an investigation and a part of that
investigation would be contacting the
parents also
i think the timing is an issue at this
point you know i think law enforcement
does things on their own schedule where
they may want the records before they
contact the parent
in that case
so i think you know we're having i think
my concern is
that this has unintended consequences of
things that haven't been thought through
because this is based on one anecdotal
situation and i'm wondering if you've
had other situations or thought about
other unintended consequences of trying
to do legislation based on one anecdotal
situation
excuse me
i think it is more than one anecdotal
situation and that this is
occurring in
a number of school districts
the same process is occurring in a
number of school districts in the state
and around the country
so i believe it's more than one
anecdotal situation
representative milo
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um your statement that
regardless
parents should be notified
and i would have a question i guess if i
was a counselor
dealing with confidential information
whether it be about abuse whether it be
about sexual orientation
etc where you have
a direct relationship with the student
that may be contrary to what the parents
believe in or what they
want
and yet this would basically say
regardless of what that confidential
conversation you might have with a child
but that information
if it's transferred to a third party
must be
given to a parent
do you have any concern about that as it
relates the impact that it might have on
the child
should should the information
relate to issues that they may not be
aware of that the child is fearful of
from the parents
i think there are also
many instances
we've seen where
perhaps
information is being
kept
by the school
from parents
that should be
communicated to the parents
that's what you and i would disagree
with
any more questions
remember that woodcut
thank you to chairman uh reverend
connelly thank you for
uh hopefully answering my question um
hopefully yeah
i'm looking at this more of the
process
in line 25 you're talking the detailed
records
shall be included
what does that mean
there there should be information put in
the student's educational record
about the disclosure of this information
but you said but the word detail record
seems to me to be
pre-exacting versus
i met with attorney walsh discussed
something
or met she received information
that wouldn't be a detailed wreck of
what but we talked and she reviewed the
records of student
steve all right
what details are we putting that record
um
that is not specified so i think that um
it has to be more than just the date of
the disclosure but there has to be more
information provided in the student
record
in line with the information that right
above that in one was provided to the
parents
okay so that that doesn't really explain
what detailed is but okay so
my fault mr chair
thank you sir um going back to
um
line 22 then number 23
it says the parents shall be informed to
whom to be released and the purpose
what is what does that mean the parent
shall be informed
uh parents shall be contacted it could
be
a phone call it could be in writing so
if if
using the same scenario before
attorney walt came in to check on uh
student steve because of something that
was was uh relevant
as a third party
so
a call from the school saying from the
council that the attorneys came in
that's it that that's informed or it has
to be and it doesn't just my question
i don't want to for me and then the
inform doesn't line up with detail
and inform is as you said could be a
call could be a talk of an email so or
but then you have details those two
words and in the data that conversation
can concern me right now
can so
yeah i i don't see any um problem
between one and two there um it uh
outlines
uh
three things that uh the parents to be
are to be informed of i would say that
would be at least um
uh provided for in uh
in two
in terms of records
thank you thank you it doesn't really
tell you what they're being formed how
to be informed what extent being formed
um and finally my last question on line
what happens if the information was not
for educational purposes
if the information wasn't does it have
to be released
if attorney walt's investigating stevie
for as perhaps have a counselor have
referred to for abuse or
or uh something else
um
does that information have to be if it's
not educational do they have to be
released
if there is an educational purpose that
would be
specified but if there was if there was
a behavioral issue um in in this case
with these grants um they could be
behavioral issues um that would be
required to be entered into the uh third
party database this says in the
educational purpose for which the
information will be used my question is
if there is not an educational purpose
does this information have to be
disclosed to the parent yes
so all information if there is a third
release that information has to be
provided yes even if it's not
educational yes
thank you mr chairman
thank you and thank you for taking my
question sure
representative cordelli can you imagine
any situation where it would be in the
best interest of the child
not to release information
to the parent
i think that
if you are providing information to a
third party
it should be the duty of the school to
also
provide it to the parent
parents can't be left out of the
equation
so you see
or you imagine that there is no
circumstance
that it is in the best interest of the
child
not to release information to the parent
there could be a whole slew of
hypothetical situations that
you know i don't know if i can uh
think of at this point but
there could be
various hypothetical situations
one more fellow
couldn't that be an unintended
consequence though that that if we're
really concerned about the best interest
of the child
and we know
that in certain circumstances
certain parents and and again
these are i assume these are parents
rather than guardians so somebody may be
a guardian of a child
and
a good reason why they're guarding the
child and not
specifically the parent
and yet the parent is being
uh advised of of
what is happening can you see that
there's a possibility problem there
since we're working on anecdotal cases
here
um you know i think hypothetical and
anecdotal kind of
near each other in some instances well i
i think here
it's not anecdotal these situations are
occurring on a daily basis in a number
of our schools so i don't consider it
anecdotal
not to be argumentative
although it seems like it's getting to
that point
my question again is that this is parent
and we have guardians
we have grandparents who are having kids
because they're the parents are
incapacitated perhaps maybe to drug
abuse
and
in with this particular amendment you're
saying that that parent
has to be notified
if there's and particularly in mental
health issues i believe
if if a child has been talking to a
counselor and a mental health person
third party uh needs some information or
or the police need some information um
by
having just the parents in this this
amendment you've you've really set up a
situation that could be
i think um
if you would like the best interest of
the job if you would like to amend this
and include um guardians i would have no
problem with that
last question right we have them
thank you mr chair i i don't know if
this is going to be the last question or
not but um but how would this read in
terms of a um
a school that contracts with a um a
third-party cloud-based student
information system
where grades are updated on a daily
basis with that with that with that
third party um uh system and would that
be considered a
um
a
currently an exempt
disclosure
under ferpa uh including school
officials with legitimate educational
interests or organizations conducting
studies or work on behalf of
of the school
and um and i guess the follow-up to that
would be
what would you envision if parental
notification and then and then
filing
notice into the into the file in such a
case where had to be done every time
data in the student information system
was updated what that would cost in
terms of
local and uh and state resources and do
we even get into sort of like a chasing
your tail situation where if you're now
updating the system to show
that
a notification that the system was
updated that you would then have to
notify the system again
in a
in a situation that really really is
chasing the tale but i'd be very
interested in
in your your um your your
your position with respect to
third-party student information systems
and frankly your position uh with
respect to the new hampshire doe in um
in sharing personally identifiable
information including students and
families addresses with the department
and whether whether that would
fall under this thank you
uh i i believe we have other statutes
that come into play and i don't remember
the rsa number
for instance with
the
company that's doing the statewide
assessment there are other statutes that
come into play with that
i don't think that that would fall
underneath that under this
ferpa provisions
i'm not sure what
pardon
the question is how could it not
student officials would legitimate um uh
with legitimate educational interest i
mean how could it not fall under the
staff but there are provisions um with
the statewide assessment for what
information what personally identifiable
information is provided there's not a
lot of personally identifiable
information
provided to that third-party company
and what is allowed is in statute in
terms of
just law that we passed last year
okay one more this is that
um what about the student that's 18
uh
something
they're 18 years of old
they're they're
um
they're in charge of their records
basically but they're still in a public
school
or in a school situation um do the
parents get notified
if anything happens on that in this
particular
um if if there's a guardian situation or
if the student is 18 i would not object
to an amendment um to add those
provisions
i would support those
okay with that i'm gonna
represent cordelia thank you is there
anyone
out there don't like to speak on this
i know no more pink cards but
we see the school board associate okay
with that i'm gonna close the hearing on
this bill
amendment
and
since we're still down it's downstairs
and hearings
in the senate
so we'll do a little recess and until
i don't know when to start the exact
session
because the senate is also having
hearings right now on
our bills
i don't know
we can't tell the senate what to do
we tried to
work out with them but it didn't work
what we're going to do is that
we are having an appropriate fire too
but we couldn't do that because of the
head going on downstairs starting at
nine o'clock
so we're going to break right now for a
short caucus hopefully it's short
they're still on the second bill down in
center head
was still online yeah still on that bill
and
there's some folks down there waiting to
speak
on bills to come up
there's not as many people in line for
those bills though so those should go
hopefully faster
but
i don't know what transpired during the
hearings this morning here
but if there is need for a caucus this
would be the time to do it
before we get together
i would say
it's based on what senator ward's doing
down there and it's they're just
dragging so i would say at least a half
hour
unless somebody wanted to make tied into
lunch as well
now i'm open to you know what what
what's
what are you thinking
yeah we're going to have an idea
well you might be able to talk about
there's five remaining bills as well
and dave and i talked this morning on
there might be two areas which you can
do some discussion
but here we are
at 11 10 now by that time zone
figuring it's going to be i would say
they're still in a second bill there's
another bill and then the legislative
oversight committee
a bill so it's i would say that's going
to be a half hour at least then we're
cruising in on
lunch
you want to just break and have lunch
and then come back at 12 30
or so are they going to have more bills
this afternoon
this morning
um
okay what we'll do then we'll
we'll we need to i need to have a caucus
because we have not discussed anything
so let's have that caucus right now
and come back and in about 20 minutes
okay
going some oh you know for the carcass
yeah
i think patty had it
has right list
of displays
okay sessions please
you ready dave
okay
okay the first bill which we're going to
address we'll just work our way down
through the menu here
sb 233 relative to water bottling
filling stations and schools
i'm going to hand the gavel over
thank you um mr chairman would you like
to make a motion yes i'd like to make a
motion of ought to pass on this uh
on sb 233
uh is there a section
of luno thank you um
any discussion by the chair yes i i'd
like to have some discussion i believe
we have an amendment for that on line
six on the second page if that's my
i'm correct so i'd like to have rep san
luna present the amendment please thank
you very much mr chair um i'd like to
offer amendment um 2022
1638h
it uh it simply amends the effective
date on section two of the bill from 60
days to 90 days and i think it reflects
um uh testimony that we heard from from
the department in terms of um uh their
ability to enact uh rules in a timely
manner uh otherwise i think the bill is
uh bill is in good shape to move forward
and i thank the chair for making a
motion about to pass
and are you making a motion not to pass
on the amendment i am thank you and i'm
second yeah
okay so we have a motion on the table
right now to
move sb
233 as amended with amendment 16. no we
got to do the amendment
right trying to get the lunch folks
uh so we'll have uh uh ought to pass on
amendment 1638
h
the amendment was proposed by represent
luna and second by representative ladd
it's a further discussion
we could do a show of hands
madam clerk yeah why don't you just ask
for a show of hands
all right
okay may i see a show of hands please
for um amendment 16 38.
it looks
okay so now we have the bill on the
floor as amended sb 233 as amended with
1638 h is there further discussion
madam clerk are you ready
this is a roll call
okay this is senate bill 233
um with amendment 1638 uh ought to pass
as amended relative to water bottle
filling stations and schools
representative ladd
hmm
no
go the other way around
i'm left
i did um representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lakers yes
representative bursting yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford yes
representative saudi yes
representative ankerberg
yes
representative miller yeah
representative luno
yes president of cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
waltz
yes representative sullivan
yes representative woodcock
representative lane
yes representative paul yes and chairman
ladd yes so this passes 19-0 any
objections to putting on consent
no objections thank you
next bill which we have on the docket
here is sb 236 establishing a committee
to study new hampshire teacher shortages
and recruitment incentives
and non-germane loan forgiveness well
that's not right now so we have the
yeah i guess and non germany that's
that's part of the title isn't it
okay
so we do we have a motion
represent hobson
yes i'd like to make a motion ought to
pass
as amended last minute
is that uh represent like a student have
a motion a second thank you
so we have a motion on the tab able to
uh
pass the amendment the non-german loan
forgiveness amendment to sb 236
discussion from the maker
on the amendment correct yes
okay so uh this amendment for the
purposes of teacher student loan
forgiveness programs seventh and eighth
grade shall be considered secondary
schools there has been a big difference
in the reimbursement rate
between
primary and secondary schools and this
change to the rsa will
provide much needed
loan forgiveness for teachers
thank you represent lakas do you want to
speak to that
i just wanted to add that when i got my
secondary ed teacher certification for
math
it was 7 through 12.
okay further
one thing we usually do we usually put
the amendments forward
after we have the bill
you know a motion on the bill itself i
don't think we've ever had a motion on
this bill have we
did representatives you your initial
motion was that
on the amendment or on the bill itself
i
was
ought to
ought to pass with amendment
well
in all honesty i was not here when i was
assigned to the duty so i was wondering
if potentially someone
could speak to uh make a motion on the
bill and i could make a motion on the
amendment
so what we need is we need a motion on
the bill
and then after we have a second on that
then we can bring forward the
non-germane amendment
we need to do it in the proper order so
any any kind of motions that we had
previously made let's start over and uh
who was the maker of the original
you can you want to take back that
motion oh uh i will rescind my ought to
pass as a mandate
and who is i resent my si i rescind my
second
base makes waste right
okay let's start this over again please
thank you uh my my mistake when we
started that i should have stopped it uh
sb 236 establishing a committee to study
new hampshire teacher shortages and
recruitment incentives do we have a
motion on the bill
uh motion ought to pass
okay
there was a second from down there
somewhere represent milor thank you and
welcome very much
representative milo having a chance to
do it formally
it's good having you back in the
committee
okay so we have a motion on the table
it's been made to
move 236 ought to pass made by represent
representing hobson second by
representative miller represent hobson
do you have anything to speak uh care to
speak to your motion
uh
i i don't have anything to add thank you
ref send miler
on the amendment no we haven't we've
just we're just on the main bill
yeah this this is an important piece
because
as an example as i was driving back uh
over the holidays
i come by i think it was new haven
and there's this big billboard out there
for encouraging people
to become a teacher
with incent with the con with the
financial incentive
so this is happening all over the
country it's happening in this state and
i think this will give us an opportunity
to really look to see what the shortage
is and what are some alternatives
to include people who may want to become
teachers in the future
and and i would like to tack on to what
representative meyer just said uh while
i was downstairs at the senate this
morning
there was a lot of discussion in the
hallway with the
chair of the state board of education
and the department also recognizes the
shortage we have in both elementary and
secondary teachers and specialists in
this state and there's a lot of
competition out there as you all know
with those that come out with the
content areas and especially the stem
areas
and and in specialty areas from industry
which is able to really you know double
payment or triple the pay that you would
get as a teacher
and people wisely are saying that's
where my future is and i need those
dollars and they're opting to go
elsewhere we're also seeing as a result
of the pandemic and what we had in the
last two years there's burnout there's
also um
it's not the same and folks are dealing
with uh they're exhausted uh
as in and you also have issues coming in
with sickness
and so with that people are opting
either to retire early or to
to leave for another what they may think
is a greener pasture
and we are short to begin with with
specialists in areas special education
especially with physical therapy and
speech pathology and and orthopedic and
and uh blindness and deaf etc and and
those people are also going to work at
the hospital level where they're getting
a number of opportunities there and
again
a difference in pace so the incentives
and the need to be looking at teacher
shortage issue is very real
and the department right now is also
looking that at this whole topic right
now with groups over there looking at
the area certification alternative
routes looking licensure etc so
the need for this is is real so that's
that's my two cents worth
um
reps and hobson do you have a further
motion to make
i do i'd like to offer an amendment
amendment number
2022-0734
is there a second
wait a second
okay so we have a motion made by
representative uh hobson and second by
represe
a uh or i mean the amendment was it was
i don't have a three zero seven eight
seven three four h
further discussion from the maker of the
motion
sure um i will repeat what i mentioned
earlier for purposes of teacher student
loan forgiveness programs 7th and 8th
grade shall be considered secondary
schools
there was a big difference in
reimbursement rates
between primary and secondary
schools within the area of one lender
and this amendment changes the rsa to
reflect that change
further discussion
yeah when i got my certification
they did tell me that secondary and this
was in the state of new hampshire they
told me that secondary meant seven
through twelve so
seven through twelve
further discussion from members on the
committee
not seeing any uh
so madam clerk can we have the we're
talking about the amendment now
to the bill where are we voting on that
amendment which is
what is his number number 73 07348
we can do a left or right hand if you
want to
uh all those in favor please put your
hands up
all those opposed
that's unanimous
okay now we have a motion on the floor
to amend
sb or for
otp a for sb 236
the amendment is 0734
h
any further discussion
okay madam clerk would you please call
the roll
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative
representative lakis yes
representative bursting yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford yes
representative soti yes
representative akerberg yes
representative miller
yes
representative bluno yeah yes represent
cornell
yes
represent tanner yes
representative waltz
yes
representative sullivan yes
representative woodcock yes
representative lane
yes roseanne paul yes and chairman ladd
yes okay the motion carries 19-0 any
problems with consent
nancy thank you very much
uh sb 350 relative to rulemaking by the
state board of education on educational
personnel applicant checks and licensing
standards
i'd like to hand the gavel over to
vice chair
uh thank you thank you mr chairman um
and i would call on the chair for a
motion i'd like to make a motion
ought to pass on sb 350
second rep san luna
yes uh i'll second that thank you
thank you um
any comments um by the chair i have no
comments
representative luna um yes thank you
very much um
uh
let's see this um uh
i i think we had um we had very good we
had a very good hearing on this bill and
had some good discussions about why this
will help to
document exactly what the department is
currently doing and one of the things
that was also presented was
was in a draft of an amendment that
was written by senator khan uh we've
prepared it in house form i think it's
gone around i think we've actually got
two ver two duplicate versions of it one
by chair ladd and one by myself
uh doesn't matter me which one mr chair
you would like to if if they're
duplicates why don't you present it then
i'm i'm happy to offer amendment excuse
me amendment 1636h
which
which which simply adds the um
uh
simply adds a provision
to uh
uh implementation of a secure system for
accessing
accessing findings of abuse for
individuals on the central registry
pursuant to our state laws and other
states central registries upon approval
of an mou by the governor and council
and i believe we uh we had talked so
that's what the amendment does and i
believe we'd talked about uh that
beginning with
perhaps the state of massachusetts mr
chair and i'll second it
um
any further discussion from the maker or
the seconder
so can we have any further discussion
on the amendment
seeing none
madam clerk maybe we can do a hand vote
please raise your hands if you're in
favor of amendment 1636-h
looks to be unanimous
so would you like to make an tpa motion
yes i'd like to offer otpa on sb 350.
the amendment would be 1636 h
second i'll second that
further
discussion seeing none um madam clerk if
you could take the role when ready
yes this is senate bill 350 um with
amendment 1636h
representative cordelli yes
representative witchfield is yes
representative boehm
yes representative lacus yes
representative berstein yes
representative hobson yes represent ford
yes representative soti yes
representative eckerberg yes
representative miller yes representative
luno yes representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
waltz yes
representative sullivan yes represent
woodcock yes represent blaine yes
represent paul yes
and chairman ladd yes so the octopass is
amended carries 19 to zero
good with consent
thank you
okay where we are right now as we're
looking at sb 352 i was not here for the
presentation of that non-jermaine
amendment
and i do have some questions which uh
and if there's going to be any of many
of that i need to speak with the speaker
or to see if that where we're going with
that
and um
so with that
uh and we have one other bill today 386
i gotta track down the speaker to find
out if an amendment to a non-jermaine
amendment how we you know make sure
that's done properly
if that's allowable
in what's going to be changed whether
it's title and then i don't think it is
allowable but i need to get some
discussion here some clarification
so um i'd like to take a
half hour break here and maybe we have
our lunch come back and wipe this thing
out very quickly and we can be out of
here by
i would hope by one
by one o'clock or 1 30 at the latest
perhaps
yeah okay perhaps before you take the
trouble of going to the speaker you
might want to find out if there's enough
support in the room for the amendment to
begin with because if the amendment's
going to fail you don't need to talk to
the speaker
yeah but i got to find out what the
amendment's going to say too
so i i what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
just take you know this this
you know maybe come back at you know
one o'clock and then
get it done
mr chair are you talking about an
amendment on 386 as well
um
i don't see anything on 386 that i have
do you
know are there any amendments on 386
represent luna not that i'm aware of
so can we exact that now
oh that this this is the um this is a
technical change that's that we were all
in the admins
this is no problem with the 386 is going
to fly either way so
so we could jump and do 386 so we can go
up get the clarification on that i'll
come back and take care of it great
okay let's uh jump to 386 relative to
the determination of state adequate
education grants and charter public
school tuition amounts
i'd like to move out to pass
was that representatives
did you make that moment i was lucky
okay thank you we have a motion ought to
pass on 386.
also
made by representative lekkis and second
by represent luna
um
is there any discussion from the maker
of the motion
just that this was all
a result of an audit that had been done
and it's just fixing problems found and
uh
it's mostly stuff that's already done so
that's it
represent luna
yes it was uh the testimony from the
department that this the documents
current procedure yes they met with us
and we need to go in this direction for
for our finances so with that um any
further discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
this is senate bill 386 the motion on
the table is ought to pass
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative
representative blakis yes
representative first seen
representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes from saudi yes representative
ankenberg yes
represent milor yes representative luno
yes representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
waltz
yes representative sullivan yes
represent woodcock yes
represent blaine yes represent paul yes
chairman ladd yes so the optipass
carries 19 to zero any problems with
consent
thank you very much so we will take a
break now and we'll come back at one
o'clock and put together
until
right
and if you're going to modify it
okay i'd like to go ahead so
we can
tackle what we have to tackle here
uh sb 352
uh this is a bill relative substitute
teacher criminal history record checks
and parental notification of
confidential student information release
we also had a non-german amendment which
was brought forward by representative
cordelli
evidently there was a lot of discussion
regarding this during the non-germane
hearing on that amendment
and um
there are some
issues that the non-germane amendment
proposes
to do which there are quite a lot of
questions that are generated as a result
of that
i think there's questions enough there
where it'd be inappropriate for us to
act on that amendment today
and to put off this action on this bill
till next tuesday when we have the other
three five remaining bills
i need we need to contact both the
department of education
uh we need also representative cordelli
centers uh
interjected here that the amendment that
he has needs
some revision
needs some changes
um that in itself would mean we'd have
to get a new amendment made
any new amendment that comes back that's
on that same topic after talking with a
cleric does not need a separate hearing
this would be an amendment which is on
the same topic that we had here heard
this morning
and it would be simply
brought up an executive session as we do
any other amendment
but i don't think we're ready to move
forward with that amendment and we may
not have any amendment but there's some
questions that need some resolution
before we move forward so with that
i don't think there's any further action
be taken today
hope everybody had a good lunch
but we don't need a motion adjourned
we're out of here
so that's it
so i thank everybody for coming back um
that leaves the six bills left on the
dock of the 13 we had that came in from
the senate six bills left which we would
address next tuesday
and those bills have to be out of
committee by wednesday
of that week
so whatever is brought forward as far as
amendments are concerned the amendments
have to be you know
the way we're going to either act on
them or not act on them
so thank you
with courage anybody that has amendments
to share those amendments with the total
committee prior to waiting till tuesday
so if you have amendments
they should will try to email everybody
so they have copies
if there are non-german amendments and
there will be a few possibly for next
week on on i don't know which bills but
there could be
those we will have of course those have
to be in the docket by wednesday by
tomorrow in the calendar so you will see
them
what's easier for you
you